do you have like other songs that didn't
make it to air that are out that are
done maybe there's a few things yeah
there's a few other songs that I
couldn't help but once to exist
Selena Gomez is spilling all sorts of
tea on Monday night's episode of The
Tonight Show I can't really tell when
but one of my favorite tracks is called
boyfriend so I can't wait for people to
hear that one yeah she basically just
confirmed that new songs are coming soon
and we think including the song called a
boyfriend which Julia Michaels recently
revealed was inspired by a text message
that Selena Center saying quote I really
just want a boyfriend I want her to
flourish yeah she deserves it she does
everything selena also opened up about
rare during her Tonight Show appearance
I had a right to save my side of this
story and I felt like I felt like that
was so liberating because it almost felt
like I had let it go personally inside
of me once it was out I wanted to make
something that was transparent yet
really classy and very real to me so I
just I guess this was the right time and
I felt it so it's crazy like it was easy
and get this
Selena worked with Phidias Billy
eyelashes brother on lose you to love me
he co-produced the track actually he we
we finished up the song and gave him the
song to produce it himself and he did an
amazing job he's obviously extremely
talented
now all this fun info comes after sell
shared a behind-the-scenes look at the
making of her newest music video and
title track of the album rare yeah so
now I'm on set for rare
it feels really good because I I so glad
that it worked out the way that it did
so the video for that I wanted it to
feel like it was a nature and how
beautiful our world is and how it can be
and and then of course I wanted some
sort of mystical ethereal look so I
thought it came out together love rare
is the song that I wish that I wish I
could just actually say personally to
every single person it's the song that
says I know that I don't have it all but
I do know that I deserve something
special and that song is exactly how I
feel I won't tolerate being treated any
other way like I told you guys so much
fun Selina info
[Music]
all right that's it for today for all
the latest I'm Celina
stick with all things et until next time
I'm Katie crafts and bye for now
[Music]